[Music]
I've got myself a secret listen about my
eternal my protects me by divine wisdom
gosh quiet shut up
they have our center run
[Music]
just some cheap
are you out of your mind he's not going
to make it he has to
but I define paste look at me all the
gold we want is right
I just came
knowledge
no breach the seal get us through that
door
all right help
bye-bye three very common by three high
way opens blood show
it says the blood of the Willing goes
Tenace me
that walks
[Music]
he's dead
as shame he didn't make it
Oh L chewed up gold supplies about three
weeks instead of four must be had me of
some well-read s
but by three they'd done by three that
way open despite a lot of them willing
hail hail the Creator it hails the
daughter what about the coin was it say
this is forbidden this is a summoning I
cannot speak don't lie to me we came
here
thanks pleasure what is this place I
don't know maybe maybe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we call the
come
tell me
I don't like the Texan it's all there is
no light here you came to the darkness
for knowledge
yes and all the knowledge you seek is
here surrender
speak the words call her home by three
they come
by three thy way or opens by the blood
of the Willing we call the home
[Music]
[Music]
daughter
[Music]
create
Oh
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
save us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome Game Director of Diablo
Luis barriga
good morning Blizzcon it is so very good
to be here
I want to thank all of you for coming
and a big thank you to Blizzard
cinematics for starting things off the
right way this weekend I know you all
want to hear about the game so let's get
to it
diablo 4 is darkness world and legacy
let's start with darkness the oblah 4 is
dark you just saw the cinematics so you
know exactly what I'm talking about
whether it's the art the story or the
horror elements that we've embraced the
first thing you will notice about Diablo
4 is that we are going back to the
franchise's darker roots it will mean
blood and gore it'll mean occult symbols
and rituals more importantly it will
mean victories are neither clean nor
guaranteed we hope you're as excited
about that as we are then we have world
also super important for Diablo 4
because we've only seen glimpses into
sanctuary and previous Diablo games but
those glimpses have enthralled us and
captured our imaginations with Diablo 4
we want to put the world of sanctuary
front and center we want every character
every monster every faction to have a
sense of place drowned Undead that
emerge from the coastlines brutal goat
men that come from the hills above us
and as we go deeper and deeper into the
depths below a truly dark gothic and
medieval version of hell
the world is also how you'll experience
most of our game it is there that you
will find enemy camps and friendly towns
alike it is also where you'll find
players to interact with whether it's to
trade with them group with them or
should you choose to do so
murder each other in PvP zones finally
legacy whether it's the sense of dread
from Diablo 1 or the classic class
lineup and loot chase that we still are
inspired by from Diablo 2 or the
best-in-class
visceral and fluid combat 2 from Diablo
3 that we still enjoy we are approaching
this series with complete reverence and
we hope that it shows if you are new to
the series we want you to feel like we
did when we first played Diablo if
you're a longtime fan we think this is
the game you've been waiting for
isometric action RPG develop for PC
PlayStation 4 an Xbox one
on that note on that note we want to
offer you a first glance at Diablo for
our long with our first three classes
the Barbarian the sorceress and the
druid
on behalf of everyone on the Diablo 4
team it is our absolute pleasure now to
share with you the world premiere of the
Diablo 4 gameplay trailer
[Applause]
the dream continues to haunt me old
friend
it always starts with a journey
to a distant blind
there I find a city in flames
streets children's with corpses
unthinkable destruction
the senseless slaughter brother against
brother pure hatred
and that executions
suffering surrounded me until my turn
comes
I break
I awaken in terror there's no one left
to stand against them
do you think me mad old friend but I
know these dreams they tell of the
future
hell is coming brother hell is coming
alright how'd you guys like that first
look we have a super exciting next
couple days ahead of us we have panels
where we're gonna go deeper into the
features the systems that world the art
of Diablo 4 starting with an unveil
panel right after opening ceremony on
this stage but that's not all
the team's been working super hard on
the game and therefore we've been able
to bring a little bit of that a little
taste for that that's right we have a
very early look a demo playable on the
floor today right now we hope you have
as much fun playing it as we did making
it and once again on behalf of the game
team thank you all and see you in hell
[Applause]
please welcome Game Director of World of
Warcraft
in Xhosa Kostas
[Music]